bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 l'aktu qui fait le tour d'horizon
comme chaque soir de votre information
locale et au début de ce journal avec
une nouvelle victoire de l'avocat à rémy
josseaume face à la mairie de montigny
le bretonneux spécialisée dans le code
routier il vient de faire annuler par le
tribunal de police de versailles des pv
de stationnement des pv de stationnement
dont les tarifs ont été jugés ils
également fixé par le maire c'est la
troisième fois en six ans qu'il gagne un
procès face à la municipalité patrick
jacques de dixmude et jonathan vilma
pour les images
nouvelle victoire pour l'avocat rémy
josseaume face à la mairie de montigny
le bretonneux
le tribunal de police de versailles a
rendu sa décision le 14 février
les procès verbaux de stationnement
dressé par la police municipale ne sont
pas conformes à la législation
les tarifs pour ces pv doivent être
fixées par le conseil municipal
ou bien le maire seul s'il obtient une
délégation néanmoins cette délégation
doit respecter certaines conditions
cette délégation doit être encadré
défini délimiter hélas le conseil
municipal a donné tous pouvoirs sans
limitation au maire de sorte que vient
cette délégation du conseil municipal
vient en contradiction avec le code
général des collectivités territoriales
c'est la 3e victoire en six ans de
l'avocat dans sa bataille contre les pv
illégaux dressé par la municipalité de
montigny en 2008 il avait prouvé que le
code de la route n'est obligé en rien
les automobilistes à afficher leur
ticket horodateur
en 2010 il a fait annuler des procès
verbaux car la mairie n'avait pas
expliqué clairement pourquoi elle
faisait payer leur stationnement aux
automobilistes ce sont donc des failles
dans les arrêtés municipaux qu'exploite
à chaque fois l'avocat pour gagner ses
procès et du côté de la mairie on donne
le sentiment d'être un peu résignés la
fixation des prix s'est passé pas limité
alors qu'on doit le limiter bon ça
toujours été fait comme ça je dire
moi je n'ai rien inventé cbc des
services qui établissent les choses
voilà la preuve je suppose qu'ils vont
encore continuer à gratter pour trouver
encore quelque chose vous savez les lois
évoluent tellement il faut en permanence
en permanence il faut se remettre à jour
donc vous savez des changements
permanents dont devra en tout cas se
méfier la prochaine équipe municipale
est avec moi sur ce plateau colette
parents coprésidente du mouvement contre
le racisme et pour l'amitié entre les
peuples bonjour colette et jean l'ambré
membres du collectif des associations
citoyennes bonjour jean l'ambré vous
avez adressé le 24 février dernier
lettre ouverte aux candidats aux
municipales de 2014
une lettre ouverte pour parler de
l'avenir des associations citoyennes qui
vont mal on va en parler
pour rappel en 2010 est né le collectif
des associations citoyennes le cac qui
regroupe six cent cinquante associations
alors le cac le mrap c'est un petit peu
un charabia pour le commun des mortels
déjà pour commencer comment on peut
définir une association citoyenne
on va commencer peut-être par par
colette
oui une association citoyenne c'est une
association qui offre dans le domaine
dd des droits de l'homme des de la
planète de la préservation de la planète
donc je donne j'étais une ong
dès l'accès au droit toute une série de
le mieux vivre le venue de vivre
ensemble
la défense aussi des par exemple des
parents les parents d'élèves quand il
est aussi une association citoyenne de
tous eu tout ce type de mouvement qui
interviennent dans le domaine
public de la sphère publique alors
conduit ces associations elle se porte
pas très bien elle se porte plutôt mal
concrètement dans cette lettre ouverte
qu'est ce que vous demandez aux
candidats des municipales 2010 2014 jean
l'ambré alors ce que nous demandons aux
candidats aux élections municipales
c'est de prendre en compte le fai
associatif
pour revenir à votre première question
sur ce qu'est une association citoyenne
il faut revenir un en 1901 la création
de la loi c'est la loi de liberté de
s'associer puisqu'en fait avant 1901 on
n'avait pas le droit de se regrouper à 2
dans la voie publique sans être
suspectée de faux monter quelque chose
de mauvais pour le pouvoir
alors cette suspicion merci c'est un
petit peu des pouvoirs ont du mal à
accepter l'idée des associations avec
les citoyens et c'est pour ça qu'on
utilise le mot citoyen que tout le monde
puisse agir prendre le pouvoir à la
hauteur de son pouvoir individuel bien
sûr c'est pas la même chose qu'un
pouvoir collectif qui est un pouvoir
institutionnel donc une association
citoyenne c'est une association où les
citoyens prennent leurs responsabilités
et prennent des initiatives
alors aujourd'hui ces associations donc
créé en 1900 comme vous l'avez expliqué
se porte pas très bien vous vous faites
un certain nombre de propositions dans
dans cette lettre
qu'est ce que vous leur demandez aux
candidats aux municipales et aux élus en
général aux élus en général on leur
demande de tourner la page la suspicion
c'est fini depuis 1901
maintenant il s'agit vraiment s'appuyer
sur les initiatives des citoyens qui
créent une association
donc il faut les soutenir alors on pense
tout de suite à donner de l'argent mais
c'est pas de la seule façon soutient les
associations on peut tout à fait mettre
des moyens disposition des locaux
gratuitement ou avec une participation
symbolique des photocopieuses des moyens
de reproduction en papier de
communication des ordinateurs et puis
aussi quelques salariés qui facilite les
tâches administratives et à nice des
associations qui ne sont pas des
administrations et qui ont donc besoin
d' aide aussi pour gérer l'administratif
je crois que vous demandez aussi qu'il
n'y ait pas de concurrence entre
associations oui ça c'est comme ça que
s'est créé le collectif de cette voie là
le cac
facile à dire plus facile à dire le
collectif d'associations citoyennes a
été créé en 2010
contre une circulaire qui avait été dit
et par le premier ministre de l'époque
monsieur fillon qui disait que les
associations étaient des acteurs
économiques comme les autres c'est ça
qui nous plaît pas dont les acteurs
économiques ont leur rôle
les associations ont un rôle qui est
bien différent qui reprend les
thématiques de l'intérêt général
donc faire que tout le monde est pareil
c'est pas bon pour la vie démocratique
c'est pas bon pour les associations
quand on est mis en concurrence les
bénévoles avec des entreprises
professionnelles il ya un problème à ce
problème on l'a observé il ya une baisse
de l'engagement bénévole ya une baisse
du nombre d'associations
quand on est soumis à une mise en
concurrence sont à remplir des tas de
papiers les bénévoles ne savent pas le
faire c'est pas leur rôle ils sont là
pour sentir ce qu'il faut faire dans la
société pour que la société aille mieux
alors je le disais durant durant
l'interview l'état d'urgence aujourd'hui
dans ces associations que vous dénoncez
dans cette lettre vous parlez de 35
mille emplois associatifs disparu entre
2010 et 2013 et 240 mille associations
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté en
france colette par an au niveau du mrap
de trappes
quelles difficultés vous rencontrez vous
au quotidien je vais devoir dire ce que
ça veut dire
alors je le rappelle le mouvement contre
le racisme et pour l'amitié entre les
peuples je l'avais dit au début vous
faites bien de le rappeler quelles
difficultés vous rencontrer au quotidien
rattrape alors les difficultés sont de
multiples aux ordres d'abord
on peut parler d'un des difficultés à
renouveler les bénévoles en sommes
maintenant tous un peu de dents
retraités et c'est déjà une première
difficulté
d'autre part nous avons des difficultés
financières nous nous parce que nous
nous sommes une association nationale
nous versons une grande part de notre
cotisation à l'association nationale qui
l as des as des salariés obligés d'avoir
des salariés des juristes notamment et
pour nous aider dans la lutte contre les
discriminations l'aide aux sans papiers
il ya des cas extrêmement pointus
extrêmement difficile à résoudre
et également pour faire son travail
d'éducation populaire comme elle comme
elle en a la vocation première à savoir
de monter des expositions de venir faire
les documents des brochures des dvd il
ya vraiment un réel manque de moyens de
bénévoles je voulais vous demander aussi
par rapport à 7 assez de l'air parce que
vous avez déjà eu des retours de d'élus
le candidat we ll faut dire que pour le
moment elle n'a été envoyée que ozil u23
commune et nous avons eu un retour
la verrière long cours et rabattre nous
en retour elle avait rien en retour
oui de monsieur david à la verrière pour
le moment nous attendons d'avoir la
publication de l'ensemble des listes sur
saint quentin en yvelines pour continuer
l'envoi parce qu'il n'a été n'est pas
toujours facile de trouver au siège les
qg de 10 ces personnes on rappelle à
nicolas mainville candidat ump et des
listes qui seront connus définitivement
vendredi
merci à vous d'être venu parler de cette
mobilisation pour les associations
citoyennes
merci beaucoup jean l'ambré merci
beaucoup crié par an et on continue le
reste de l'actualité avec le 30 novembre
1921 henri désiré landru qui fut
condamné à mort à versailles pour le
meurtre de onze personnes à vernouillet
et à gan b onze personnes dont les corps
n'ont jamais été retrouvés
les étudiants de l'association juris
tribune de l'université de versailles
saint quentin ont reconstitué ceux
proposés ont reconstitué ce procès est
proposé un nouveau jugement
romain gravette et jonathan vient
maintenant henri désiré landru et dans
son box son procès peut avoir lieu au
tribunal de grande instance de
versailles
il est accusé d'escroquerie par contrat
de mariage ainsi que du meurtre de
diffamer d'un enfant comme il ya près
d'un siècle à vernouillet et à gambais
dans les yvelines
les étudiants de l'association juris
tribune de l'université de versailles
saint quentin ont décidé de remettre à
l'ordre du jour cette affaire déjà jugée
en 1921 henri désiré landru avait alors
été condamné à mort dans cette même
salle mais cette fois ci le jury
pourrait prendre une autre décision
en glanant des faits des événements se
remettant si un peu dans le contexte de
l'époque on a pu comme ça construire nos
argumentation nos plaidoiries et se
faire aussi une condition parce que
c'est quand même un sujet qui a été
sujet à polémique et puis il a fallu
aussi qu'on se fasse une idée
la culpabilité ou pas de monsieur landru
toute la difficulté elle était justement
de ne pas se laisser totalement
influencé par le procès qui s'est
déroulé donc à l'époque et de pouvoir
vraiment donc conserver une certaine
improvisation au moment de la
reconstitution du procès cette
reconstitution permettent aux étudiants
de vivre un procès ce qu'ils n'ont pas
l'opportunité de faire au sein de
l'université
ils ont essayé au maximum de restituer
tous les éléments du dossier à commencer
par les preuves et les témoins c'est un
travail de recherche donc il suffit de
chercher dans l'eau sur internet faut
vraiment croise énormément de source
parce qu'on trouve vraiment tout et
n'importe quoi dans des livres dans des
archives
on a passé des coups de chiffres c'est
vraiment un travail de recherche
approfondi complique ensuite avec des
connaissances c'est juridique
la défense aura été plus convaincante
cette fois-ci qu'en 1921 puisque
l'accusé a à nouveau été reconnu
coupable mais seulement condamné à la
perpétuité du sport maintenant avec le
golf de feucherolles qui a accueilli ce
mercredi la première étape de l'afutt
golf cup 2014
alors c'est l'occasion de découvrir ce
sport méconnu fait pour les anciens
footballeurs en quête de reconnaissance
anthony rech et jonathan littman il ne
porte plus le même maillot et pourtant
ils continuent de frapper dans le même
ballon mais sur un parcours de golf avec
des chaussettes hautes un gilet et un
béret vous êtes au fond du golfe
les règles sont celles du golfe sauf
qu'ici pas de clubs seulement des pieds
pour faire entrer le ballon dans un trou
de 55 cm de diamètre en un minimum de
coups pas si facile
même quand on a marqué près de 100 buts
dans sa carrière de footballeur ça
paraît simple sa part été sa vie on a
l'impression que c'est très simple mais
finalement les distances sont
relativement faussé par rapport aux
enfants un terrain de foot où c'est
beaucoup plus rapprochés la cia la
distance est dure à jauger et après on a
forcément le terrain face il faut
frapper on a toujours peur de se blesser
mais c'est très sympa né aux pays-bas en
2009 la discipline compte désormais
seize fédérations dans le monde
l'argentine a d'ailleurs remporté la
première coupe du monde en 2012 et la
prochaine pourrait bien être organisé en
france
mais pour cela les fous de golfeurs
doivent
d'abord être acceptée sur les greens fin
2014 on espère avoir deux mille cinq
cents licenciés et à horizon de trois
ans et d'avoir entre cinq et dix mille
licenciés qu'ils puissent va commencer à
pratiquer on sait que pour ça de toute
façon ça passe par le fait que les que
certains golfs nous accepte pour une
pratique régulière parce que bon venir
jouer comme ça une faute aux tendances
c'est marrant c'est ludique mais c'est
vrai que je pense qu'un acquis pas s'y
prendre
se prendre au jeu et commence à avoir
envie de jouer régulièrement comme au
golf ou comme en foot 3 golfe viennent
de signer un partenariat avec
l'association française de football pour
accueillir ce nouveau sport les pays-bas
venus en masse à feucherolles ont marqué
leur territoire en remportant l'épreuve
par équipes de cette première étape de
la foudre golf cup 2014 c'est la fin de
ce sept huit scènes actu on se retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition avant
de se quitter je vous rappelle le débat
ce soir à 20h sur notre antenne les sept
candidats à la mairie de maurepas
s'affrontent sur notre plateau un débat
arbitrée par wilfried richie dans un
instant c'est le fils d co présentée
comme chaque jeudi par claire cambier
excellente soirée sur télé